welcome
everyone thank you for joining us for
today's presentation
titled floated tuzu map an
investigational
cd 123 cd3 by specific dart
protein induced clustering of both
cd3 positive t cells and cd123 positive
aml cells
in bonbon marrow biopsies and the
association
of this drug with response to treatment
in primary relapse
acute melloy leukemia patients
it is my pleasure to introduce to you
professor jan
davidson professor davidson is the
director of clinical development
and research at macrogenix company
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab
at the top of your screen in addition if
you have any questions
during his presentation we encourage you
to submit these questions
in the qna box the speaker
will get back to you will respond you by
email
so without further delay please join me
and welcome
dr davidson you will not i will now turn
the presentation to him
hello my name is jan davidson from
microgenex
i want to thank nanostring for inviting
me to participate
uh in this conference advancing science
in oncology i will be presenting today
uh our work on uh
flotitusomab which is an investigational
cd123 by cd3 by specific dark protein
uh which is being currently developed as
salvage
immunotherapy for refractory acute aml
um acute myelin leukemia is a highly
heterogeneous disease
uh despite the recent introduction of
several new therapies
aml remains a very difficult to treat
with many patients being either
refractory to current available
therapeutics or relapsing
relapsing shortly thereafter the
treatment paradigm has not changed
significantly
significantly in many decades with
patients being satisfied
by their ability to tolerate high-dose
cytotoxic chemotherapy lots of these
patients that
are refractory or relapsed shortly
thereafter
are usually treated as a single clinical
entity however uh it is now well
recognized that these patients differ
not only
in their success of subsequent salvage
therapies but also
uh in some of their immune immunological
phenotypes
uh these patients with primary induction
failure early relapse
are usually recommended to uh uh undergo
uh further clinical or to be involved in
further clinical
studies and there's really no any not
any real approved therapy for those
patients
slow detousimab is a bi-specific
antibody based molecule to cd3
epsilon and cd123 engineered in a dart
format
cd123 is a low affinity interleukin-3
receptor
alpha is expressed in about 60 to 80
percent of patients with aml
what makes cd 123 particularly appealing
as a therapeutic target in aml
is not only that it's highly expressed
it's high expression in aml blast but
it's also associated with poor outcomes
furthermore cd123 is also putatively
expressed in aml progenitor and stem
cells
cd3 engaging by specific molecules like
floridatuzumab
bind both the tumor and the effector
cells to promote an immunological
synapse and redirect polyclonal effector
t effector tumor to kill tumor cells in
an
mhc independent fashion
so
so essentially theoretically filtered
tutomap is a pro drug and the active
moiety of the
reaction is the t cell flotitusimab
engages t
cells in the context of cd123 aml blast
which leads to t-cell activation
expansion and differentiation
cytokine release ensues as part of the t
cell function which leads to aml blast
killing
due to the mode of action of t cells
uncoupling
killing activity and cytokine release
which is an unexpected
and as expected but unwanted side effect
is challenging
and i will speak a little bit more to
that further on in the top
in this slide what we see is the example
of florida two zombie activity
this is a bone marrow biopsy taken from
a patient treated
on flotitusomab uh on the left hand side
of the
of the panel you see the baseline biopsy
with cd3 stained
in in a yellow city 123 stained in red
and that b what is very interesting uh
to see
is that upon treatment with flotituso
map the patient develops
very nice t cell clusters
surrounding city 123 uh positive cells
or aml blasts
in this uh highlight section what you
see is a very nice interaction of the
cd3 cell
with a cd123aml blast which occurs in
the context
of in the context of florida two zomb
administration the next slide
this slide what we see is we using
geomix dsp
multiplexed quantification of 50
plus io proteins uh also allowed us to
get
further insights into the cd3 clusters
we initially selected geometric regions
of interest covering the whole tissue
and then compared protein expressions
between the rois
with and without t cell clustering what
was very interesting is the t
cell that these t cell clusters showed
markers of
t-cell activation namely cd27
cd44 and cd45r0 as well as negative
immune checkpoints
with a higher expression of pdl2 ctla-4
and i-cos
moreover we also analyze match based
samples
pre and post samples using the pan
cancer io
assay and we found that treatment with
flow detousin map modulated
the tumor microenvironment flow detusmap
was associated with an increase
in test scores antigen processing
machinery and interferon gamma scores as
well as pdl1 expression
the lidar finding was also confirmed at
the protein level
in one patient with evidence of
anti-leukemic activity
of floatitus map using geomics digital
spatial profiling platform
for the highly multiplex quantification
of these proteins the volcano plot
in panel c shows how pdl1
expression as well as other interferon
inducible proteins including sting
was significantly upregulated in post
cycle one uh floated twos enough
so in conclusion from this uh section
what we see
is the floatituzumab uh a
the mode of action of florida tuzumab
which is uh in uh
involving t cells in the context of uh
of aml blast leads to activation
proliferation
uh and aml uh lysis by t cell activity
next i'll talk a little bit about the uh
the clinical study
and how we um and some of the
correlative work that we've done with
with within that study so this is a
clinical study it's a phase one two
first in human dose escalation study
of florituzumab uh the bi-specific uh
protein in patients with relapse of
refractory aml
the study has been designed in two
phases a dose escalation phase which has
been completed
and has defined the maximum tolerated
dose and the recommended phase two dose
to be uh 500 nanograms per kilogram per
day in a continuous infusion
uh the the study in the inclusion
criteria
included refractory maml which is
defined as patients that are refractory
to two induction attempts
or first relapse with an initial cr
duration of less than six months
or hma failure of greater than four
cycles
relapse aml was defined as initial
response rate lasting more than six
months
a matter prior history of hematopoietic
stem cell transplant was exclusionary
and what we will do is we'll present the
data of the first
50 patients treated at the recommended
phase 2 dose
this slide highlight this table
highlights the overall demographics of
the patients uh the 50 patients recom
treated the recommended face to those
what we see is that
uh 60 of the patients treated the
recommended face to those
met the criteria of refractory disease
that is primary induction failure
and early relapse the majority of the
patients had
adverse risk criteria
based on the eln 2017 criteria
and 36 percent of these patients had
secondary aml
these patients were all heavily
pre-treated with the median prior lines
of therapy
uh of three lines of therapy but ranging
between one
and nine prior lines of therapy so
overall
collectively these patients represent a
very poor risk population
with few effective treatments and
otherwise limited life expectancy
the overall safety analysis identified
uh infusion-related reactions
and cytokine release syndrome as the
dominant adverse event for florida
twosome map
which is expected based on the mode of
action of floriditus amount
of the patients with irrcrs the majority
had mild to moderate signs and symptoms
with only four percent experiencing a
single grade three event
no grade four or five irr crs events
were recorded
other non-irr crs treatment related
grade three events
were less common
so what we know what we've learned so
far is that more crs events rcrs events
occurred in the first week of treatment
and gradually decreased with continuous
dosa
so rrcrs seems to be a first dose event
and not necessarily a c-max event
most events occurred in the first 48 to
72 hours
and decreased thereafter the incidence
of
decreased each week during continuous
dosing at the maximum tolerated dose
there's an increase in incidence of
events were noted upon the drug the dose
interruptions
so one of the things that we emphasize
is to try to maintain
a continuous dosing of lotutuzumab to
try
to minimize cytokine release syndrome
what we did find is we did find an
association between anti-leukemic
activity and
incidence of rrcrs there's no such
association with
noted with irrcrs severity
which is highlighted on the graph on the
right however
what we do see is that
with the number of rrcrs events or days
of crs events during treatment
corresponds with a greater decrease in
bone marrow blast in the
in the in the bone marrow so
consequently reducing the severity of
our
rcrs did not appear to preclude flotitus
maps and
leukemic activity and the gold on the
study has been more to blunt
rather than to eliminate rrcrs
so on the study we have implemented
several mitigating strategies
to try to uh um to try to control crs
the first uh thing that we have
implemented is prompt use of
uh tosilisma the impact of ptosilism
in florida tusa map induced rcrs is
noted on the
left-hand side by the higher levels of
il-6
in patients that have received uh
tosilisma socialism is an il-6 receptor
blocker and hence upon
administration of tosilisma
there's a higher level of circulating
analysis in the blood
uh and this is anticip so hence the
greater level of il-6 in the patients
after dosing the proceduralism
is anticipating giving the drugs mode of
action
on the right-hand side we see the
promptos elizabeth
usage was associated with a decreased
duration of ircrs events
with an average of 1.8 days versus 1.2
days in patients that had not and had
been administered closely close
elizabeth
the second mitigating strategy that
we've implemented
is a sequential uh increment of uh
leading dose
uh in cycle one uh in week one of cycle
one
what you see here is um upon
administration the study when first
designed
was um administered uh floated to zuma
initially at a hundred nanograms per
kilogram per day for week one
thereafter stepping up the dose to 500
nanograms per kilogram for day one
in the middle ground you see the uh
incidence and severity of crs
in after the one step leading dose and
then
after that we implemented a lower step
up dosing at 30 nanograms per kilogram
per day
before going up to 100 nanograms per
kilogram per day and then stepping up to
500 nano gas per kilogram per day
what that did was it did reduce the
severity of crs in week one
as well as week three and week four
highlighted by the blue line in the
middle graph
however that was still sub-optimal and
that is noted
by the lowest intensity that is seen on
the
right hand graph with a dose intensity
of
uh uh 50 59
of of intended dose we next
um included more steps
uh in the step dosing in uh in week one
so a more
gradual multi-step leading those and
what that did is did
overall reduce the severity and
incidence of
our rcrs notably in weeks two
three and four and that is also
reflected in the much higher dose
intensity
that we see upon introduction of the
multiple leading dose
so from 50 percent to about 80 percent
at dose intensity
by implementing implementing those two
uh
um strategies we have managed to uh
maintain um crs
at a very low grade of grade one and two
here you see uh of all the events that
were documented in this cohort of
patients
uh most of the events were grade one
fifty-seven percent of the events were
grade one
forty-two percent were grade two and
less than one percent of the events were
grade three also notably crs events are
short duration with uh grade one events
uh lasting a median of one day grade two
lasting a median of two days
and the only grade three event
documented in this cohort of patients
lasting three days
however it the event peaks at grade
three
during these these 72 hours but doesn't
really
the patient is not in grade 3 severity
for for that duration
so now we'll focus on aflotectuzumab
activity at the recommended phase two
dose
um what we see this waterfall plot shows
uh
the 50 patients treated at the
recommended face to those 45 of those
patients are
valuable five patients uh progressed on
peripheral blood blast and hence did not
reflect it in the waterfall plot
39 patients are on the waterfall clock
the unstudy complete remission rate is
is a 13.3
with a crcrh rate of 20 and a complete
response rate
of 22.2 one of the things that we've
been very
interested is in identifying the target
population
hence is not to over treat patients that
would be unresponsive to fluoridation
map
and focus more on the patients on the
right-hand side of the waterfall plot
that would be the responsive patients
so one of the things that that we know
um
we've learned is that 40 to 50 percent
of patients with newly diagnosed aml
um failed to achieve a complete
remission or complete response with
intensive
induction therapy these we name uh
namely primary induction failure
patients
and uh other with this experience this
or
experience disease recurrence after a
short remission rate
those are early early relapse patients
and
looking at the literature we note that
these patients the probability of these
patients responding to salvage
chemotherapy
is is very low and hence usually the
recommendation for these patients is to
be treated on clinical study
what is interesting about these patients
is that primary induction failure or
poor prognosis has been associated with
increased immune infiltration in the
tumor microenvironment
and high cd123 expression on aml blast
so we were interested in trying to uh
trying to explore
these two notions
this is work uh this slide summarizes
work of
sergio rutela who is also a presenter at
this conference
and a close collaborator collaborator
and what he did is he in the discovery
of 62 patients with newly diagnosed aml
treated with curative intent on a
cytarabin-based
chemotherapy backbone what is
what is noted here is a supervised
hierarchical clustering of the
of a correlative matrix identifying
three distinct immune
gene expression profiles in the bone
marrow
tumor micro environment and what you see
here is namely innate
adaptive and exhausted uh uh
gene expression profiles so what we did
is we
explored the gene uh the immune gene
signatures
uh in in de novo aml patients
that were treated with curative intent
as as i mentioned before
and what was interesting about that is
that uh these patients clustered into
two separate uh immune clusters
namely an immune infiltrated cluster and
an immune depleted cluster
what was interesting about this was that
based on the fact that there was a
clinical outcome data available
what we see here is that patients with
an immune infiltrated cluster
did not respond as well to cytotoxic
chemotherapy
as patients with immune depleted
tumor micro tumor microenvironment
and interesting these immune scores were
better predicted
predictors of chemotherapy resistance in
the aml discovery
cohort than the eln cytogenetic risk
classifiers
with areas under the uh areas under the
curve
and values of 0.815 compared to 0.702
for the eln risk category and these
findings were further validated in
silico using transcritomic
data from the baml master trial
which is shown in panel b
so what we next did is we
what we next did is uh we applied
uh we applied these uh
the we interrogated patients that were
treated on the florida twosome
study in a similar way using
the pan cancer io 360 panel and what we
see here in the right
on the left hand block is that these
immune signatures
uh segregate the patients treated with
florida two zombies into two clusters
again clusters that was immune
infiltrated as well
uh as immune depleted at baseline
and what we noticed is the patients with
refractory disease
had higher level of um
um immune
immune interferon gamma scores as well
as uh inflamed uh
chemokines t scores and interferon
downstream score related in relation to
patients with relapse disease
also when we look at these patients in
relation to patients that had
anti-leukemic activity
defined by by a decrease of more than 30
percent
uh of bone marrow blast uh compared to
non-responders
patients that showed evidence of uh
floridatusumab anti-leukemic activity
also hired higher levels of interferon
gamma module score
as well as a test score and these were
uh
good predictors of response to
floridatusumab as shown
as shown in the areas under at the au
rocks of 0.86806
and 0.847
so overall what we see is that
as opposed to uh showing
being predicted of cytotoxic uh
resist of or being predictive of
cytotoxic resistance
aml patients with high immune
infiltration
we're very susceptible to our response
to
uh flow detusimap as you can see here
with a
higher complete response rate of 41.2
versus 7.7 in immune depleted
uh patients and comparing uh
areas under the curve the interferon
dominant signature in aml
was not only very predictive of um
chemo resistance with an auroch of 0.92
but also very predictive of floritusomab
uh
anti-leukemic activity with an um
aurora of 0.85
so if we now uh go back to our waterfall
plot and we overlay
uh uh in that waterfall plot overlay
the aml status uh on coming on to the
floated twosome map
uh study as uh primary induction failure
early relapse late relapse or hma
failure what we see is that the patients
that are responding
to florida two zuma are the patients
with
primary induction failure disease and
early relapse
so what we've now tried to do is define
that population as the population that
is sensitive
uh to florituzumab that specific
population the risk the complete
remission rate
is eight nearly 18 for the valuable
patients
with a crcrh rate of 28.6
and a complete response rate of 32.1
uh interestingly uh meta-analysis of
published data uh in aml
and for uh primary induction failure and
early relapse
uh population shows that uh as a
historical
benchmark uh for response uh with
uh current uh treatments for this
population is 12.5
which is um which with which the patient
population with very dismal
prognosis
so uh in conclusion um
consistent with florida tusma's proposed
mechanism of action this data highlights
a dynamic induction
uh of an increase in t cell
infrastructure and clustering of
around cd123 aml cells in the bone
marrow micro environment of aml patients
that respond to treatment
the geo mixed dsp analysis identifies
that these
t-cell activation or t-cell clusters
show
t-cell activation markers with increased
expression
of peace activation markets including
pd1 pdl2
um floatitus map treatment and aml
showed a
manageable safety profile leading those
strategies in early toes eliza map usage
have helped to blunt the severity of crs
the interference-related gene signature
in baseline bone marrow was associated
with resistance to cytotoxic
chemotherapy but a response to flow
ditusine
which leads to defining the target
population as the primary induction
failure population which is a high unmet
need
in that population the historical data
indicates the best response to salvage
therapy
of 12.5 but a clinical response
to floridatusumab approximating 30
in these heavily pre-treated patients
who failed aml
uh prior therapies overall i want to
acknowledge
uh and i'm grateful for the patients
and their families who participated in
the study and i'm very
uh grateful for great collaborators
including sergio rutella from nottingham
trent university
uh sarah church and the team at
nanastring
and bernie fox and this team at the earl
childs research institute of course the
team of microgenics
is a fantastic team and we're grateful
for the clinical trial
teams and all this at the study sectors
thank you very much
so dr davidson i had a few questions one
is the following
if i follow correctly refractory
aml provides an immune landscape that is
favorable to this particular drug
my question is is this environment
intrinsic to a particular
aml subtype or is it is it a consequence
of prior lines of therapy
okay thank you very much for that
question uh it's an interesting question
um uh what we do know at this point is
that
uh this this uh immune flame uh
environment is not as intrinsic to for
seems to be intrinsic to particularly
to aml as a whole what we have done is
we've looked
at uh de novo aml patients who can be
segregated into these two clusters
we have not seen this associated with
any particular aml
subtype except for the fact that p53
we just recently sergio
rutella presented some data showing that
p53
aml is is associated with uh
increased immune infiltration in the
tumor microenvironment
this does not seem to be a consequence
of prior lines of therapy
another question to ask is can different
chemotherapies or treatments
provide an optimal tme for frustration
map
we don't believe that different
chemotherapies
uh can affect the tumor microenvironment
at least we have not seen that
in our studies what we have seen is that
hypomethylating agents
can modify the tumor micro environment
namely
uh uh more than three cycles of
hypomethylating
uh therapy in our patients
uh has been associated with increased uh
expression uh of uh
pdl1 and other checkpoints uh
hence uh potentially uh obviating the
response that closes the flotitusomab
the anti-leukemic response that floated
to the map could induce
and finally one particular question also
that i wanted to ask
is what has been the key to ensuring
safety profile for this particular drug
when other drugs that target also cd123
and cd3 by specific
antibodies have stalled also
didn't cd123 car t cells fail due to
safety
so in other words what is critical here
about this drug compared to previous
experiments
safety profile in florida to zuma
has been the drug has been manageable
we believe that one of the um
one of the uh
we believe that one of the uh effects
that that has helped us and try to
control uh toxicity with florida twosome
is the fact that the molecule
is uh the half-life of the molecule is
very short
hence a lot of the toxicities that have
been noted with other cd123 targeting
reagents
as well as cd123 card t cells
can be mediated in part by the dosing
strategy that we've
implemented as well as those elizabeth
but also
by the fact that some reduction in
dosing
during an acute event uh quickly leads
to resolution of that event
because the half-life of the drug
so we at this point we don't we we don't
uh
have a particular threshold that is
associated with uh
a threshold inflammation that is
associated associated with florida
twosome map
we are further exploring this the idea
would be to try to define
a predictive biomarker or selection
biomarker that we can
potentially select patients by using
them
and we are definitely looking at uh
using
uh markers in the peripheral blood that
could
um uh be used instead of
uh relying on uh um
you know more invasive bone marrow
biopsies to identify the patients
so overall we find that flotitusinmab
is associated with responses in patients
with
immune infiltration the tumor
microenvironment
these patients usually are associated
with these patients are usually
associated with cytotoxic
or with resistance to cytotoxic
chemotherapy
and hence it identifies a population
with high unmet need
that can be treated with florida twosome
map um
the computer with florida two zombies
thank you very much for allowing me to
to share our data